I've been pondering for a while on the  idea that a lot of our environmental  impact comes from overconsumption our  fuel of food of just general stuff and I  think a lot of that overconsumption  comes from a rather misguided desire to  be happy and we've been told by the  advertising industry that if we buy  these products we will be happy and it's  been shown that that's just not working  basically we're trashing the earth and  it's not even making us happy so if we  could disconnect those two things if we  could start looking for our happiness in  better relationships at better work/life  balance in greater equality in our  societies and a stronger sense of  community I think at the same time we  could boost real human wellbeing and  reduce our environmental impacts and I'm  really excited to see this message  springing up in lots of places around  the world right now and in fact the  United Nations has formed a working  group to bring this out globally